on observe sa dégringolade depuis un bon
moment déjà en juin 2014 le baril de
pétrole valait plus de 100 dollars ce
mois-ci pour la première fois en dix ans
il a plongé sous la barre des 30 dollars
mais au delà des enjeux économiques
quand on parle souvent quel impact le
pétrole bon marché at-il sur l'avenir de
la planète
bonsoir katrina sa cellule alors du
pétrole pas cher ce une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle pour la lutte contre
les changements climatiques mais écouter
sinon on serait tenté de croire que
pétrole meilleur marché ça va vouloir
dire que les gens vont consommer plus et
ça va rendre les énergies renouvelables
moins attrayante
en fait c'est un peu plus compliqué oui
en 2015 on a vu une forte hausse de la
demande de pétrole à l'échelle mondiale
ça tarde à se stabiliser la pour 2016
par contre on a vu aussi des
investissements majeurs des records en
fait en énergies renouvelables 329
milliards de dollars américains ça c'est
du jamais vu donc oui le prix du pétrole
baissent mais le prix des énergies
renouvelables
aussi il baisse est bon on sent que la
transition énergétique
elle est en marche et les fluctuations
du prix du pétrole ne vont pas vraiment
l'arrêter on sera certainement pas à
court terme donc un pétrole plus
abordable veut pas dire qu'on met de
côté les énergies vertes et ça peut
aussi on peut mettre fin aussi à des
projets qui sont assez pollue en fait
oui en fait si on regarde au canada le
seuil de rentabilité pour les nouveaux
projets d'exploitation de sables
bitumineux se situe entre 70 et 90
dollars le baril on est loin de ça le
présentement selon la complexité du
projet on a annoncé cette année
l'abandon de trois projets qui auraient
à huy représenté des investissements de
1000 yards
dollars mais aussi des milliards de
tonnes de gaz à effet de serre aurait
été émis dans l'atmosphère donc mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'économie bonne nouvelle
pour la planète
un autre volet qui est intéressant c'est
l'insee celui des subventions octroyées
à la consommation des combustibles
fossiles
on l'oublié souvent mais dans beaucoup
de pays le venezuela par exemple on
garde les prix du le prix du pétrole
artificiellement bas pour que ce soit
abordable pour la population mais ça
fait en sorte qu'à l'échelle mondiale
il ya plus de cinq fois 40 milliards de
dollars américains qui sont octroyés en
subventions aux combustibles fossiles
c'est quatre fois plus que ce qu'on
octroie ou aux énergies renouvelables
c'est vraiment une joute à armes égales
on s'en rend compte et là comme le prix
est très bas que ça fait en sorte que
les gouvernements peuvent peu à peu
réduire ses subventions là sans
s'attirer les foudres de la rue on l'a
vu en inde en arabie saoudite à bahreïn
et les voitures électriques pendant ce
temps oui il en arrive parce que c'est
plus d'excusé pas plus difficile pour
elles de concurrence
oui certainement à ce niveau là on a vu
en 2015 des ventes de véhicules
utilitaires sport de camionnette qui
était en cause mais quand même au canada
et ça c'est durant des états unis où les
véhicules hybrides les véhicules
électriques stag ici quand même il ya
une croissance des ventes
particulièrement à ouvrir au québec et
on a vu aussi le nombre de bornes
électriques bondir de 85 % dont il ya
quand même une vision à long terme
lentement mais sûrement voilà on y
arrive et merci beaucoup katrian prix